we've got aromatic lean lamb chops with
char grilled broccoli and bulgur wheat
salad for dessert it's healthy mango
sundae
holly
[Music]
then i can help daddy with the dessert
yes please and the lamb cutlets
now
we all know that you love desserts yeah
yeah we'll do a little
yogurt parfait with some macerated
fruits
so the first thing i'd like you to do is
take a tablespoon
of icy sugar dust that over the fruits
good
now sad enough that's perfect thank you
zest the orange over the fruits and
what's going to happen now it's going to
start to sort of marinate i'm going to
put some basil in there
that'll make it really flavoursome
fresh puzzle in
and then we need to give that little mix
up
i'm gonna squeeze
some fresh orange juice in there
nice and gently
okay
how gorgeous do those berries look now
okay
so we just leave them just marinate okay
and that's what we call
macerated berries
now for the mango sundae
right mangoes in
please i love mangoes
nice
now they're naturally sweet okay
one that smells incredible
now
how fresh
does that smell very now you'd love art
right yeah i do so you're going to put
these together so a nice little dollop
of mango at the bottom nice and slowly
once each glass has a layer of mango
puree at the bottom
spoon over a layer of thick natural
yogurt and alternate until the glass is
full well done now they're yummy from
there you get your berries
you sit your berries on top
they taste so fresh
but now they've been marinated
and the berries have been slightly
macerated and then finally look
get your icing sugar and just tap
on top
they
look it's beautiful
now they sit in the fridge to get nice
and chilled okay
so
if i take three
and promise not to sneeze
and you take one and open the fridge
door
good
job
desserts chilling in the fridge now for
the super simple main course to go with
the aromatic lamb chops a tasty char
grill broccoli and bulgur wheat salad
to cook the bulgur wheat just simmer
until tender then drain
to give the broccoli a char grilled
flavor simply cook with salt in a hot
dry pan until smoky and tender
for a quick and easy aromatic dressing
mixed together harissa paste with either
buttermilk or creme fraiche and add
chopped mint simple as that
to serve thoroughly dress your broccoli
and burger wheat and finish with more
fresh mint leaves
dessert ready and salad's done now for
the aromatic grilled lamb chops
how much do you love lamb holes
a lot a lot on a scale of one to ten
ten okay these lamb chops are gonna be
delicious
first i'm gonna marinate them i'll start
putting the spices in yeah first one
coriander coriander good so a teaspoon
of coriander seeds in a little touch of
what's that human human well done cumin
in
one of daddy's favorites
turmeric chew me a teaspoon of that in
there
now
a little touch
of salt
and then i want you to start grinding
that down while i get the ginger and the
garlic
give that a nice little mix
please for daddy
that looks amazing after that get the
garlic lay it flat
and look
it almost purees the garlic so we get a
nice paste
see underneath sorry about dirt in your
nails
it's okay
i just smell like garlic now nothing
wrong with that
the more you smell of garlic
the less the boys are gonna date you
sorry
right now the ginger
makes it sort of
spicy
and fruity now get the ginger and do
exactly the same with the ginger when
you grate it like this it turns into the
most amazing
ginger puree off you're dying
come on holly put some muscle into it
good girl
nice see all that there you got the back
of the knife
now i'm gonna drizzle some olive oil in
there okay and you bring that together
as a paste for daddy there you go
stuck on no it'll come off
nice
good girl
now
that smells incredible that
is a delicious paste
so i'm gonna tip
all that marinade on
to the lamb
and then i want you to rub it all in to
those lamb chops
then we go get your hands in there my
girl
come on holes
so look you get them in there then you
rub
all that marinade
the flavor inside these chops come on
holly that's right come on
your jumper's fine
just
smell that
nice
and the earlier you do this the better
the turmeric is starting to stain
the lamb chops they're not even cooked
yet yet they smell delicious yeah
what do you like honestly oh my nails
oh my
nails delicious after marinating from 10
minutes to overnight but if you can't
wait to get your hands on them you can
grill the chops strain away gas nice and
high and grilling them
is going to make them slightly healthier
so
lamb on
first one
in
we'll slide that in
alongside is that so you sit more in the
pan that's right what i want to do is
get those really nice
grill marks on there
[Music]
see
come on
now we're going to cook them
three sides
one side up flip it and then on the back
see this bit here yeah i'm gonna grill
it on there as well
[Music]
now if you could get the yogurt out of
the fridge please daddy
nice
some fresh mint
i want you to pick
the mint please and give it a little
chop and mix it in with the yogurt
smells amazing doesn't it
so yogurt
in
chop up
the mint please
have a look
at the color
of the lamb
oh that's
beautiful
so nice does it
how nice
are they
they smell incredible
grilling them this way they cook so much
quicker
okay it's a lot healthier
smell those
beautiful excited yes barry
good eric and megan will like those i
hope so
[Music]
see what i'm doing i'm standing the
chopped up yeah
yeah we're not going to dry out this way
is that chopped enough try a bit more
that's fine and then mix it
into yogurt please this isn't too hard
is it dad not a salt my darling
how would you know when they're done
nice and pink three and a half to four
minutes each side
medium
six minutes well done
eight or nine minutes
how would you like your landmark
medium rare that's what i always go for
a lamb cutlet at its best
will be medium red off with the gas
okay
it's got a lovely
lovely flavor
okay
look at that
wow
i'm in heaven
i'll carry the lamb
and the yogurt if you get the bowl of
weeds and the broccoli they're done that
smells incredible it really does
fast and easy to make packed with
goodness and utterly delicious with a
bit of kitchen know-how you have my
ultimate healthy dinner on the table in
just 30 minutes
mom until the perfect meal for any busy
family
a stunning prawn and cucumber salad with
a spicy yogurt dressing
a simply delicious anchovy dip
and a sticky chocolate fridge cake that
won't fail to revive a flag in family
until he's keen to get in on the action
[Music]
what are your favorites a marshmallow
and peanut fridge cake
perfect for
a picnic first things first we have to
slowly melt the chocolate
that's bad that's good
i'm gonna break up the chocolate
right in there
next butter goes in
couple tablespoons of golden syrup
it's so good
if we melt chocolate too quickly it
starts to separate and destroy
the best and safest way to melt
chocolate is always use a bain-marie but
i'm going to keep a really close eye on
mine and heat it over a super low heat
this stunning little cake has your
favorites in there our digestives now
put your hands in there and give them
like that one at a time ago
and crush what's the one thing that you
love about a picnic
i love eating outside especially on a
nice summery day
not so much in the wind today no
that's gonna be the crunchy part of our
fridge cake
and it's called a fridge cake because it
can sit in the fridge or you can freeze
it
now peanuts in please
can you use it without peanuts if you're
allergic to peanuts oh you can do yeah
definitely now
what are these little babies cranberries
cranberries
from there
marshmallows my favorite okay
they're so bright aren't they why do you
love marshmallows so much because
they're so squishy all right give that a
nice mix up
chocolate is melting nicely okay i want
you to pour that in and i'll mix it nice
and gently slowly slowly slowly
nice
now
touch more please
good isn't it good give that a little
mix with daddy please look they're all
melty nice and cool and gooey
now we're going to line the tray
so this is quite easy to make because um
you don't have to bake it
you just set it yeah i want you to start
pushing it into the corners please with
your fingers just laying out nice and
flat
ah it's all nice and marshmallow and
oozy
to get the spatula okay and look
how delicious does that look
really delicious i can eat it right now
i couldn't because it's not set
so when that sets okay
it'll go nice and firm and then we can
cut it into little bars little squares
triangles triangles
[Music]
good
but the important part pushing it down
is that we can slice it
and the more we push the thinner we can
slice okay
[Music]
fridge cake done
now i'm gonna make the most amazing
anchovy dip with vegetables and bread
first cut slices of baguette and bake in
the oven at 180 degrees c for six
minutes or until crisp
meanwhile roughly chop garlic and
shallots and add to a food processor
along with a tin of good quality
anchovies
sprinkle in some pitted black olives
flat leaf parsley and drizzle in the
reserved anchovy oil and a little olive
oil
blitz to a paste and add pepper then
decant into a jar ready to transport
serve with a handful of fresh baby
carrots
peppery radishes and your crisp baguette
toast
anchovy dip a portable and deliciously
palatable alfresco treat
[Music]
now a spicy chilli yogurt dressing with
a prawn salad first things first i'd
like you to make the dressing
fish sauce
doesn't really smell like fishes so one
and a half tablespoons of fish sauce
two chilli
i like this especially if you have it on
the side of the pork
little teaspoon of sugar
oh that's it good
in
so four tablespoons of yogurt
three
four
some zest in there
why are you making it in a jam jar not a
bowl well this is for a little picnic
and it's a great way of transporting
we squeeze the lime in there and then we
put the lid on shake it
and then i want you to shut it on tight
[Music]
come on it's a bit like a tummy
see
that sounds like my tummy
only sometimes only sometimes thank you
for that
hi nick is you
and the first time you have it's like a
little thingy it's fresh
salty citrusy
but delicious
now cucumber and the salad i want to get
rid of all the seeds so if you just nice
and gently
peel the cucumber why do you feel it can
you not eat the skin on it you can eat
the skin but i want this salad to taste
light and fresh
you can use a knife for this too though
can't you you can peel with a knife but
the speed peeler takes off the slices
nice and thinly so much quicker so much
quicker that's why it's called a speed
peeler
looks better now looks a bit naked it
does look a bit naked doesn't it
now you get your spoon
and see
what happens
a teaspoon just takes out all those
seeds
so whilst it sits in the dish
it doesn't make the salad go all soft
because that cucumber is nice and
crunchy
[Music]
that's really good
there you go so see where your knuckles
are there
that's what's always going to protect if
you put that little finger out
this little piggy
boom comes off what did i tell you about
daddy's knuckle that's the first place
you cut off
all the time there you go
the next addition to our prawn salad is
firm juicy baby gem lettuce look at the
lettuce in half what about
the butt
the butts
[Music]
i'm keeping the butts on for now so when
i slice it it stays together
okay
and then a little bit there
we don't use
okay
when you prepare lettuce for a picnic
you never slice it too thinly
okay otherwise it will it's good prawns
are ready
[Music]
your tummy sauce is ready your dressing
is ready take the lid off
and the trick is
you dress
the bottom of your dish because i'm
going to put the prawns on here to
protect the lettuce
get your cucumber
i put my cucumber on
and then finally that is
okay
now the salad's not gonna go soft why is
that because it's not that it's not
straight onto the dressing that's right
what happens is we wrap this now and
then we get to our picnic drizzle the
sauce on top we mix it up
we've got the dressing on the bottom and
the dressing on top
of the dressing on top that's right
a little bit of tim film do you know the
cling film check i don't know the clint
field trick yet no thing fell over the
top of the toilet
what you don't understand it when you're
my age
oh you've been my age then well okay
salad in the fridge with the dressing
ready to go for a picnic
is my ultimate picnic dinner feast
prawn and cucumber salad with a spicy
yogurt dressing
anchovy dip with crudites
and the kids favorite chocolate
marshmallow and peanut fridge cake